I want to start today talking about Florida.
And yeah, in a certain sense, this is a story
about Ron DeSantis, but it is really a story
about Ron DeSantis as governor, not Ron DeSantis
as the maybe future failed Republican presidential
primary candidate Ron DeSantis, who still,
as of this moment, has not announced that
he is running against Donald Trump in that
Republican primary.
I want to show you the texture of the right
wing hellscape that DeSantis is rapidly transforming
Florida into now.
Full disclosure, I know people e-mailing,
but David, you say these things about Florida
and then you go to Florida.
Okay.
I also said things that are terrible about
Donald Trump, but I lived in the United States
when Trump was president.
So, yes, there are parts of Florida that I
think are great, even though they have infrastructure
problems as a result of of Ron DeSantis and
right wing state policy, those liberal parts
of Florida with the good restaurants, as Alex
Jones would say, yeah, I frequently go there
and I don't understand how that devalues in
any way the criticism of the policy that the
Santos has put in place.
So CNN recently had this list that they put
up.
Let's take a look at it.
In recent times, Ron DeSantis has signed a
six week abortion ban, ended concealed weapons
permits.
The requirement for such permits ban gender
affirming care for trans youth.
Restricted drag shows expanded the don't say
gay law blocked and an advanced placement
African-American studies curriculum class
and prohibited vaccine mandates.
First of I am going to make two arguments
to you here.
First argument, all of these bills and laws
are terrible ideas.
And number two, many of them also directly
contradict the stated values of low government
intervention, little government involvement,
freedom and liberty that they claim to espouse.
So let's go through some of these six week
abortion ban.
DeSantis signed that in a closed door ceremony,
I believe it was last month.
The bill prohibits physicians from performing
abortions after six weeks into a pregnancy
in most cases.
As I've explained before, many women don't
even know they're pregnant until the six week
mark.
Because when you've missed your period, if
you are pregnant, you're basically five weeks
pregnant for five, depending on who you ask
or, you know, the particulars of that.
So it is completely unrealistic, absolutely
unreasonable.
And it is close to a full abortion ban.
It also says that if you want an exception
because you've been raped, you have to provide
evidence of the rape.
Okay.
If it's the result of incest or human trafficking,
you need to provide evidence and that only
gets you an exception up to 15 weeks.
This is if Roe v Wade were still in place,
it would blatantly violate Roe v Wade.
It's another attempt to control women's bodies
and limit choices.
And it is insane.
Government overreach.
We have the bill that lets you concealed carry
without a permit.
Okay.
DeSantis signed this also last month.
This allows gun owners to carry firearms in
public without any additional permitting or
training required.
And it also ends the state requirement that
when you leave your home with a concealed
weapon, you must have special training or
even special training, I think is what we
would call it.
It's a gift to the gun lobby.
It's a gift to the NRA.
It's a gift to the more guns in more places.
And it will make Florida less safe.
It will make Florida more prone to gun violence
and accidents.
We then have this package of five bills that
were passed and signed into law by Ron DeSantis.
And here we are talking about a lot of bills
that relate directly to the rights of the
LGBT community.
And here we're talking about a ban on gender
affirming care for trans youth.
This will prevent doctors from providing hormone
therapy or surgery to minors who identify
as trans.
You could argue that it is a form of denial
of medical care, that you're just you're taking
away medical freedom, because what we're talking
about here is saying, hey, here's people who
may need certain services as determined by
medical professionals instead.
You have some Republican lawmakers saying
you're not going to be allowed to do it.
Restrictions on drag shows.
This is a law that will prohibit any establishment
that serves alcohol from hosting performances
by drag queens or drag kings.
You can argue that this is discrimination
against a form of artistic expression.
You can argue this violates free speech because
at the end of the day, we're not talking about
grooming or pedophilia or sexual assault or
any of the things that they love to say are
inextricable from drag shows.
It's a form of expression and it's a government
banning that.
We will see what happens.
There's the expansion of don't say gay.
Don't say gay prohibits teachers from discussing
sexual orientation or gender identity.
Except does it.
Are you allowed to say as a female teacher,
Oh, my male husband.
Well, that is a discussion of gender identity.
But that's not bad because we know what the
real point of it is.
It's to censor and silence LGBT voices, experiences
and the reality that all sorts of different
types of people exist in our society and culture.
There's the bill in addition to this, which
we talked about before, that blocks the Advanced
Placement African-American studies class from
being offered in public schools.
Remember, they framed it as they are forcing
this indoctrination onto our children.
It's an optional class, in my experience.
It's not as though advanced placement classes.
Are exactly super popular.
I mean, they often fill.
But what I mean is it's not like the entire
school is you're looking to take these classes.
It's a whitewashing of history.
It denies many of the struggles of black Americans.
And we've talked about it before.
And then lastly, a bill that bans any vaccine
mandates by any entity in Florida that includes
businesses, schools and government agencies.
Now, whatever your feelings are about a COVID
vaccine requirement, and I'm there with you,
if indeed the COVID vaccine doesn't prevent
transmission, there is a case to say it shouldn't
be required.
The counter would be if it reduces the chance
of hospitalization and death.
For military readiness.
It certainly seems like it could make a difference.
But my point is step back from the COVID vaccine.
Think about how reckless and irresponsible
it is to say you can't have any vaccine requirements,
that you can't have any vaccine mandates when
we have so many vaccines that do prevent transmission
and are quite literally public health.
God sense, there's probably some better word
I could use that's less religiously oriented.
These are bills that are harmful to Floridians,
but they're also harmful to democracy.
And many of them run directly counter to the
stated values that these Republicans claim
to espouse, which is they say freedom, liberty,
do whatever you want government only involved
when absolutely necessary.
Freedom of speech, freedom of expression.
Except, well, no drag shows and no doctors
and patients deciding what's best for them
and all these other things.
The takeaway is their principles evaporate
as soon as they conflict with the political
reality that they are trying to fight